- [David] Hello readers.
You know what's better
than reading a book?
Reading two books.
Reading a bunch of books.
Reading a mountain of books.
This may sound self-evident,
but great readers read a lot of books.
Good readers read widely.
They read lots of
different types of books.
Sometimes these books will be similar,
and sometimes they'll be very different,
but one thing that good readers do
is think about how what they are reading
might connect with other books
they've read in the past.
They think about how books
connect with other books.
I have been reading a lot this year.
Mostly cookbooks, mysteries
and science fiction novels,
so they're alike in some
ways and different in others.
Right now, I'm reading
these mystery novels
that take place in Australia.
They're all written by the same person
and they all feature the
same main characters.
A collection of books that
are about the same character
in different situations
is called a series.
Reading a series is a great way
to see how the same
characters grow and change
over a longer period of time.
There's the hero of the series
with a fabulous feather in her hair
and a magnifying glass ready
to solve some mysteries.
Now not all books by the same author
are automatically part of the same series.
Authors can write standalone books
or start completely different series.
Here's the author hard
at work on a typewriter,
an ancient writing device.
If you don't know what that is,
politely ask an older person.
Often, writers have a
similar writing style
even when what they're
writing is not connected.
For example, if you like funny books,
and you find an author
that makes you laugh,
chances are that the
other books they write
could also be funny.
Books can have similar plots.
So the series I've been
reading is a mystery.
The main character is a detective
and she figures out how and
why someone committed a crime.
After many years of reading,
I've learned that I really like books
that share this quality,
of a hero that solves mysteries.
But, just because two
books are both mysteries
doesn't mean they're going
to work the same way.
Two mysteries by two different writers
with different characters and situations
are going to be pretty
different from each other.
As a reader, I have to
be careful not to assume
that I know where a book is going to go
just because I'm familiar
with what kind of story it's telling.
It's like fairytales, right?
Every culture around the
world has traditional stories
and those stories all pretty
much have the same purpose
which is to teach people how
to behave like a good person.
There are stories all around the world
that have a similar structure
to the story of Cinderella.
Young, poor girl with an evil stepmother,
unfairly punished and then through magic
and the goodness of her own
heart, she marries into royalty.
There are thousands of
versions of this story
from every culture on Earth.
I love reading stories
from all over the world
because it helps me understand the values
that different cultures share
or how they differ.
This is why it's fun
to read lots of stories
from different times and different people.
It can help us understand
what's important to people,
what was important to people in the past,
or what's important to us now,
and it's fun.
Reading lots of books is fun.
You might find an author or
a character that you love.
You might be transported to
a whole new land or time.
Reading widely and thinking
about how books connect
is the best way to become a better reader,
and you might just solve a mystery or two
while you're at it.
You can learn anything, David out.